[Music]
I'm Nick uh I run playo I've been making
POI videos and photos since 2002 I've
got a vision right now um both with the
videos and with the photos I would love
to bring that Vision to life this
patreon page makes it all the easier um
you can pick a perk starting at a dollar
a month a recurring that uh helps
support me as I do all of this and over
here is the different goals of what that
money will help me with um and I should
I'll add um you know vegan ice cream and
I'll be posting exclusive content here
including videos and articles about how
to take good photos of fire dancing and
po spinning if this goes well I'll just
have a little more time each month or I
can really focus on being creative and
then sharing that with you and the world
in general if you think that would would
be awesome uh pick any perk you like and
I will appreciate it so much and then
I'll see you back here um and we'll go
on from there
[Music]